Good morning, John,
it's Wednesday... What am I doing here?
It's Wednesday, that's not how this works. It's weird!
Okay, it's gonna get weirder. John, you know that I love
documentary films, and I know that you do, because
we're nerds. But I think they have a problem, because
we're busy. Not just with work and
stuff, but with
all the distractions
that-- I'm gesturing toward
my computer right now. There's a giant crisis looming around every
corner, and if we don't want to
look at that, and we want to look at, like,
cute or funny stuff, there's
always a place to go look
for that. And you can do that really fast,
and have, like, a 15-second thing, or a 15-minute thing
and documentaries, though... they're long.
They're often much more slowly paced than a lot of our
media these days, which is, like, "AHHH, I gotta be doing stuff, all the time".
Even if it is, like, a really efficient way to learn something, we
don't feel like it is? But they're one of the most effective tools for giving us insight
into our humanity, and into the lives of other people
or other animals. Documentary film
is fantastic, but more
and more I feel like there isn't a good place for it.
There's not a good, like, "okay it's time now
to have this kind of experience".
Which is why we were pretty excited when YouTube Red came to us and were like "we have this idea..."
They had recently acquired
the rights to this new award-winning documentary that everybody's talking about
and they wanted to make it available to YouTube Red subscribers. But YouTube is weird;
it's a bunch of channels that already exist,
you can't just create a new
channel every time you have a new documentary.
So they asked us to watch the documentary, which we did
and we both loved it, and then if we did like it,
maybe we could talk about it on the vlogbrothers channel, and then
upload it here, for YouTube Red subscribers. Now I am aware that
not everybody has YouTube Red or can get YouTube Red, though there is a free trial available right now.
It's only available in some countries, and not everybody has ten bucks
a month to spare: I understand that.
But if you do, the film is either now available, or will very
shortly be available on the Vlogbrothers channel.
It's really good, it's got like a 97% on Rotten Tomatoes, it's...it's a good thing.
It's a movie about street cats in Istanbul. It turns out
that Istanbul has a really interesting
relationship with its cats. They're cared for
by the humans of Istanbul, but they don't tend to be owned by
any one person. Ah, look, I'm a cat person. There's
something magical about them. And there's something
appropriate about how this movie, 'Kedi', asks us to slow down a little bit, and be okay
just spending a little bit of time, watching pretty pictures
and compelling stories
about the lives of these cats. Because that's one of
the great services that cats provide:
They get in your way. They say "Hey, stop what you're doing.
Me! I'm beautiful! And soft! Stop with the
computer-staring and give me some chin-scratches". They lead by
example, showing us that it is okay to sometimes, just--
exist. And that is what this film, which Variety called
"quietly magical", asks of us. To just exist for a little
while. I was able to spend a little bit of time talking to the makers of this film,
Ceyda Torun and Charlie Wuppermann,
and Ceyda said something in that chat
that I thought was really lovely and poignant:
that the relationship between people and cats is one of the only relationships
with another species that people don't dominate.
Cats exist with people of their own accord, y'know?
And looking at myself through a cat's eyes
gives me a perspective that I think is really hard to find other ways,
and I think that it's really well discovered and shared in this movie.
I hope that everybody who can will join me in watching this film.
John,  you will see me for my regularly scheduled video on Friday.